a lot of those guys lost money they can
afford to lose money my
worry is when it pops a lot of
other people are going to lose money and
maybe there will be people who can't
afford it
my name is gary stevenson i work for
years in the city betting on financial
markets and now i'm an equality
economist
i'm going to tell you what's happening
with gamestop what it means for the
global economy and how it's going to
affect you
there's a section of reddit called wall
street vet it's full of
some interesting people very passionate
about markets
and some of them are clearly very
intelligent some people went on there
and said look
some hedge funds have put massive short
bets on
this company gamestop because they think
it's a not strong company
if we go and buy all the stock then when
they come back to renew their loans of
the stock they're borrowings of the
stock we can say no we're not going to
give it to you
so they just created a sort of an army
of people to go out buy a game stop
massively push the price up not loan it
out to any hedge funds and then when the
hedge funds
had to renew their borrowings of the
stock to sustain their shore
they couldn't do it so they had to buy
it back and the price by then is
10 times as much so these guys bought it
here held it so the hedge funds couldn't
have it and they had sold it back in
which obviously when the hedge funds
bought it again pushes the price even
further up historically there've been
some instances where like hedge funds
have done it with like food like wheat
they've put all the wheat and then the
people well obviously you need wheat
they say oh well they push the price up
you just the idea is
one person one group of people buys all
of it corners it and then the people
that need it have to pay inflated prices
i guess what is new here is it's been
orchestrated
on an internet messaging board uh which
is not
traditionally how it's been you know the
big narrative is it's um
a load of you know plumbers and
electricians and taxi drivers at home
training on their laptops in the kitchen
to be honest given the level of
sophistication i suspect there are some
professionals involved but
the truth is there is a large army of
ordinary people who are sitting at home
it's largely americans you know not all
americans but largely americans
using their stimulus checks which
they're getting while you know a lot of
them can't work
to i guess they would see as fight
against the big piles of wall street
is the issue that wall street has with
this now
the behavior or the fact that it's other
people who are manipulating the market
and not wall street
if it was wall street banks making a
fortune on this then there would be less
of an outcry from the wall street banks
i mean
i've worked in wall street i wasn't
involved in the big level politics or
the lobbying of it but
these guys are out to make money these
guys are to keep power and to keep
market
you know market power i mean i can
understand what's happening right look i
think
you need to put it in context right
first of all when the koi with crisis
what's happened is a lot of people a lot
of people lost their jobs
lost their incomes stuck at home it's
been awful
but what's important is to understand
it's been way more awful than some of
them for others right the richest 10
people in the world
have made enough money just last year to
pay for covered vaccines for the entire
world
the really rich people here are making a
fortune here while ordinary people
are sitting at home lost their jobs you
know and in the us they've
been given the kind of support that
we've been given in the uk which you
know
that's helped some but it's not been
complete coverage um
and that comes on top of a context of
since the 2008 crisis what has happened
the 2008 crisis the economy has been
terrible for 12 years
and yet stock prices trebled quadrupled
house prices in london have doubled the
gold price has trebled
so we've been living in a world here
where ordinary people the wages don't go
up the jobs don't get better
yeah i think at the very heart of it
what is it is work isn't working
work don't work will not buy you a house
in london you know what i mean
i'm 34 people my age who work a job who
don't have don't come from rich families
you cannot buy a house
no and but then they see city traders or
people from wealthy families
buying them easily so then if you create
a world where work doesn't work
and wild gambling seems to be able to
make you money and it only seems to go
to rich people
of course ordinary people they're not
idiots they're going to say we want a
piece too
but i don't want to frame that as if
this is a massive success for the
ordinary person
because the truth is that gamestop is up
forever maybe it's maybe it's 2 000
it just changes all the time but at some
point that's going to collapse i
guarantee it
and when that collapses who's going to
be holding it i'll put you any money
it's regular people who are sitting out
here
saving up their money who've been
working hard jobs trying to make money
for their families
at the end when it collapses it's
probably going to be ordinary people
i don't want to give people the
impression that you know ordinary
you know the working man can take that
control by
betting on robin hood or ig index or
spread brain because
truth is 75 of people that use these
accounts lose money
and it can be very dangerous it's
gambling it can be addictive it can ruin
families so
i totally understand the story i totally
understand the story i can see
inequality blowing up listen i come from
a poor background
i'm rich now i totally see what is
happening in the world and i understand
how it affects people
but we are not gonna save the world by
sitting at home in our kitchen
trading stocks in our underpants should
we feel bad for
the the wall street brokers
the hedge funds for losing all this
money if so
or if not why i mean
i'll be completely honest i'm not going
to be crying myself to sleep about huh
i used to work in the city and i don't
want to give you the impression that
it's full of full of [__] or full
of
unpleasant people there's definitely
some but um there's also a lot of good
people there just trying to make money
for their families you know that's what
i was trying to do you know what i mean
um i don't want to create this good and
evil narrative but um
look a lot of those guys lost money they
can afford to lose money
my worry is when it pops
a lot of other people are going to lose
money and maybe there will be people who
can't afford it